quand est-ce que tu as appris sa mort tu
étais où
je me suis levée avant de chair à 5h du
matin mais c'était comme c'était comme
si je suis désolé je suis pas la même la
même personne aujourd'hui j'ai du mal à
prononcer mes mots
c'est à dire que la journée avant avant
j'avais une sorte de
prémunition je me suis réveillé à 5h du
matin avec un mal de crâne et j'ouvre
mon portable je reçois un message de loy
Klein qui est c'est comme un frère qui a
Miami il me dit désolé for you lost mes
condoléances
à Love You Mindel i'm so sorry et là il
met pas le nom de la personne
à 59 ans c'était mon ex mon ex-fiancé
dans dans 3 ans c'était quand même aussi
quelqu'un de violent parce qu'il a été
arrêté avait par rapport à son ex-femme
qu'il avait un petit peu tapé je voulais
savoir si les raisons qui vous avez
motivé à partir à l'époque c'était des
violences domestiques